[Music]
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers the og of
the franchise Aaron from 1993 to 1995
for three seasons and a hundred and
forty five episodes a lot of episodes
this show was so iconic to me as a kid
it got me into karate that is true
really made me into the woman that I am
today now we're going to count down the
nine most iconic most memorable and
sometimes yes even heartbreaking moments
of Mighty Morphin Power Rangers so in
hindsight this first moment actually
isn't as iconic as I remember because
three actors left due to
behind-the-scenes drama that was like
unbeknownst to me at the time they did
it in a very non flawless way of using
body doubles and dubs and stock footage
to explain the transition and looking at
it now it's very obvious
Zordon we can't go to the peace
conference not now it has to be another
way yeah as a kid
huge moment as an adult kind of
hilarious but it is the time that we
meet the movie cast the entire movie
cast together in one room so coming in
at number nine its Trini Zac and Jason
leave the Power Rangers I present to you
the new Power Rangers
rocky atom facing zack treaty power up
we're gonna see him again soon I'll
really miss him we're gonna miss him
so bye season 2 of the series we've
dealt with 60 episodes of Rita Repulsa
Goldar and all her kind of literal punny
villains so at this point they decided
to introduce a new baddie someone who's
gonna stick with us for the rest of the
franchise leave their print and number
eight it's the introduction of Lord Zedd
I will give you back
[Music]
now this show could have easily stuck
with the same formula every episode of
Rita's making something grow but they
didn't you know they did multiple
episode arcs of this series so by
episode 19 of season 1 it seems like the
Rangers have finally met their match
with Evil Green Ranger Tommy Oliver
played by Jason David Frank and during
this five episode arc there's a moment
when the Red Ranger Jason is trapped in
a Dark Dimension for like two episodes
and it really seems like he's done for
so at number seven its Jason Lee Scott
is trapped in the Dark Dimension left to
fight Goldar and Tommy alone you're only
prolonging the inevitable Jason you're
not begging me for mercy human because
you know I never granted
[Music]
I thought Reda wanted me to destroy him
she wants that pleasure to be mine and
has ordered me personally to see to his
end kind of that so unlike Trini Jason
and Zacks departure the showrunner spent
some time giving Kimberly the Pink
Ranger a proper setup admittedly this is
when I stopped watching the show because
Kimberly was like everything to me and
this was like ginger leaving the Spice
Girls so at number six its Kimberly's
exit I promised Kimberly from the bottom
of my heart that I will do everything I
can to carry on as you would I know you
will gather
now if you were a kid in the 90s and had
feelings tell me and Kimberly's love
story destroyed your heart and by the
35th episode we finally get the moment
we've all been waiting for
number five Tommy and Kimberly's first
kiss
[Music]
I've been wanting to do that for a long
time me too
such a moment but before this Kimberly
and Tommy were shameless flirts and
unbeknownst to her she's about to find
out the true identity of the evil Green
Ranger this is moment number four it's
coming together
oh man
no way
can't believe look I don't believe it
[Music]
so at the end of evil green Rangers five
episode arc the spell finally breaks and
Tommy is asked to join the Power Rangers
moment number three will you join us
Tommy
[Music]
all right then it's morphin time dragon
triceratop favor do dagger to an a sword
recovery we're not backing down with
Power Rangers let's go all the way back
to the first episode which by the way
the whole thing is straight-up iconic
it's our introduction to the Rangers as
we knew them but to narrow it down to a
single moment after these teenagers
attitude and they have so much attitude
reject the idea of becoming Power
Rangers they're defeated by putties so
coming in at number 2 it's the Power
Rangers more for the very first time
what did we do now Thorin said these
poem work was to give us power let's do
it
[Music]
Triceratops or
now what could be the most iconic moment
from Mighty Morphin Power Rangers well
we talked a lot about Tommy Oliver but
of course he was defeated and he lost
all his powers and the gang was in need
of a replacement at this point they know
they're getting a new ranger but who is
it this is moment number one the White
Ranger welcome White Ranger the time has
come to reveal your identity
[Music]
guess who's back so yeah I don't know if
you can argue that another moment tops
that one but maybe you have some
opinions about the way things were
ordered or maybe a moment I didn't even
mention that you're kind of freaking out
at me over let me know on Twitter or of
course leave a comment in the comment
section we have one of those thanks so
much for watching keep Morphin
[Music]
you
[Music]